harry potter's given us this amazing
chance to break into an industry which
is really difficult to get into can you
imagine tom felton as harry potter what
about ron weasley
the fact is we could have gotten either
just because an actor is rejected for a
role doesn't mean they aren't any good
because some really amazing actors
didn't book the parts they auditioned
for in harry potter which famous child
actors came extremely close to being
part of the franchise
let's check it out
i don't know about everybody else who
are the new people but i was just so
desperate to look cool circa ronan
quickly made a name for herself with
roles in brooklyn little women and
ladybird my name's ladybird it's weird
you shake hands yeah
but years before her success she faced a
pretty devastating rejection from the
world of harry potter one day one of her
spells went badly wrong
the actor was very young at the time too
young to take on the role but it didn't
make losing the job any easier missing
out on the opportunity really stung
since ronan was a big fan of the books
and used to think of performing in harry
potter as the best job in the world
truth is
actually
i'm in love he stole our hearts in love
actually and wowed us in the queen's
gambit playing on cheap plastic boards
with cheap plastic pieces we can only
imagine what his portrayal of ron
weasley would have been like that's
right the then 10 year old actor who
never actually went through any formal
acting training faced his first really
tough rejection when he wasn't given the
role of the redheaded weasley
that's wizard's chest
i see you've packed brody sangster
learned an important lesson about
staying optimistic i do remember
thinking though that the next time i
went in for an audition i'd have to put
up a shield to stop myself from getting
hurt since then he's never been as hurt
when he misses out on a part hattie
jones first became well known for her
role in madeline and was actually a
front-runner to play hermione in the hp
franchise the decision of who would
perform the role was actually just
between jones and emma watson in the end
ultimately the producers felt jones
looked a bit too old for the role at the
time so they went with the then
nine-year-old actress emma watson who
rose to worldwide fame
i know what you did malfoy
in tom felton's case the third time
really was the charm since draco malfoy
was the third role he ended up being
considered for in harry potter and the
philosopher's stone the actor's first
audition was for the boy who lived next
up he read for ron weasley but
ultimately wasn't the right fit for
either eventually he was considered for
the role he was meant to play the slick
slytherin draco malfoy see weasley
unlike some my father can afford the
best robin williams was a legendary
actor and stole our hearts in multiple
roles and there was a chance he could
have done so again as hagrid in the
harry potter franchise williams even
called director christopher columbus
expressing how much he wanted to be in
it however since the actor wasn't
british he didn't make the cut since the
goal was to have an entirely british
cast
aina soul knows how except for me and
dumbledore
once upon a time a boy in university
named eddie redmayne went in for an
audition to play a young tom riddle but
unfortunately he flunked it the actor
knew it didn't go well since he didn't
even get a call back even after the
rejection redmayne hoped for years that
he might still be cast as one of the
weasley siblings but unfortunately it
never came to pass
however he did finally get to join in on
the magic when he played newt in the
fantastic beasts franchise
probably shouldn't let him loose in here
though
jason isaacs was initially not looking
forward to auditioning for lucius malfoy
the actor actually almost turned down
the role since he felt it was too
similar to his appearance as captain
hook in the 2003 peter pan it actually
took a family member convincing him to
say yes when the part was eventually
offered
that wasn't the beginning of his harry
potter journey though isaacs actually
auditioned for the role of professor
lockhart first
i decided i should win him some sympathy
so you see me bully him mercilessly
before he became superman cavill was up
to play the hufflepuff heartthrob cedric
diggory
he's serious
the actor was such a popular choice that
there was even a petition made by fans
to have him cast but of course robert
pattinson beat him out little did he
know at the time he'd lose out another
role to pattinson cavill was actually
the first choice of stephanie meyer to
play edward cullen in twilight but the
production went in a very different
direction and cast pattinson once again
let's give it a try do you feel ready
while we know david theulis for
portraying the beloved professor lupin
we almost got a very different first
impression of the actor who originally
auditioned to play professor quirrell
however the role wound up going to ian
hart who thulis also cast in a movie he
was directing years later so there were
definitely no hard feelings when
auditions for the third film were
happening he was brought in to play
lupin and told hart about the offer
hart's reaction
it was the best part in the whole book
we definitely agree with that
jude law was brilliant as a young albus
dumbledore and fantastic beasts but we
were almost introduced to him as a
professor at hogwarts gilderoy lockhart
his audition was great and the actor was
in the mix but ultimately the team felt
the actor looked too young for the role
we're glad we wound up getting to see
his dumbledore
he's a really rare and a really
extraordinary experience while he did
get to play the second most powerful
wizard of all time gelert grindelwald in
both harry potter and the deathly hall
as part 1 and fantastic beasts the actor
had actually originally auditioned to
play a not so great character
one of the young tom riddles
while the grindelwald actor was really
hopeful he'd win the role of tom the
part ended up going to frank delane i
fashioned myself a new name a name i
knew wizards everywhere would one day
fear to speak the narnia actor william
mosley was actually in the mix to play
the boy who lived mosley has wondered
since then what his life could have been
like had he booked harry potter upon
reflection the actor himself didn't feel
like he was actually the right fit for
the part while he no doubt would have
had an incredible time as the boy who
lived if he had to choose between harry
and peter mosley would choose peter
every time so things definitely turned
out for the best
peter wolf spain
knight
of narnia
with there being a strict no-non-british
actors rule it was almost unheard of for
anyone that didn't fit that profile to
audition liam aiken had an in with
director christopher columbus since the
two had worked on stepmom together
what's really heartbreaking about this
situation is that leah macon was
actually offered the role of harry
potter however just a day later the team
took it back since aiken wasn't british
there was a time that actor richard e
grant was being considered for the role
of lucius malfoy the actor had impressed
the team and was a definite contender
for the role but eventually lost out to
jason isaacs loses one questionable
father figure only to be replaced by the
likes of the two of you the vampire
diaries actor joseph morgan's first
major audition was actually for a harry
potter film fresh out of drama school
morgan was ready to dive into the world
of acting when a woman had called him
using an anonymous number she'd let him
know that she had gotten him an audition
to play tom riddle in harry potter and
the chamber of secrets the woman was an
agent looking to represent morgan and
with an offer like that he couldn't
refuse
the actor was fully committed to doing
the best job he could in the audition
reading the book and sticking up a harry
potter poster on his wall to fully
immerse himself he got close with a
callback but ultimately lost out
the harry potter movies would have been
extremely different if any of these
actors had been cast in the roles while
they no doubt would have brought great
performances to the screen things seemed
to work out as they were supposed to
it's hard to imagine the films without
any of the actors we've grown to know
and love which actor would you have
liked to see in a role
[Music]